mayor Bernard Sanders of Burlington
Vermont how does a socialist like
yourself keep winning elections in a
country we generally consider that has a
two-party system well I think we win in
Burlington I should point out that in
Burlington I am the mayor and i won on
four occasions but we have 13 people on
our city council board of aldermen and
six of them are progressive so it's not
just me we have probably the only strong
three party city in the United States of
America and I think the reason that we
win and continue to win is that
increasingly people are frustrated and
angry about a two-party system which is
dominated by big money and which does
not pay attention to the needs of
working people or elderly people or poor
people and I think if you talk common
sense to the people and you say the
government is supposed to represent the
needs of those people who today are not
getting a fair shake you know what
they'll vote for you and the problem
that we have nationally in this country
is that the two-party system dominated
by big money I is not delivering for
ordinary people which is why people are
giving up on the political process why
they're not voting and why they're there
is a great deal of anger and frustration
at the political system as it now exists
how and why did this happen in
Burlington well I I don't know I mean I
can't really tell you i think in
burlington what we did back in nineteen
eighty one is we pointed out the
inadequacies of the previous government
and we've knocked on a lot of doors and
we talked common sense to the people we
articulated the issues that i believe
were concerned for the people and since
i've been elected we've continued to
focus on those issues we have said in
our view is the government has the right
to get involved in any area that makes
sense you don't get involved in areas
where it doesn't make sense previously
we had not had youth programs we really
didn't have good arts programs in terms
of our waterfront development we were
too prone to give it over to wealthy
people and condominium development
rather than preserving it for ordinary
people so I think we just took the
issues to the people we knocked on doors
we work very hard and lo and behold
people responded and I think the message
that I'd like to convey to people is
that if you go out in your cities and in
your towns and your talk common sense to
the people you can win and we should not
be overwhelmed or frightened by the
powers of the Democratic and Republican
parties
I don't believe that they really have a
lot of grassroots support I think the
most people vote Democrat they vote
Republican because they don't see any
alternative and it seems to me that the
challenge of our time is the wake people
up is to go outside of the Democratic
and Republican Party to talk about the
real issues health care the fact the
growing gap between the rich and the
poor in this country the bipod us and
foreign policy of which we spend 300
billion dollars on military why we cut
back on programs for the elderly
healthcare housing I think if you ask
people whether I mean just recently
what's been coming up in terms of the
Congressional pay raise here you have a
Congress which is giving themselves a
fifty percent pay raises proposing to do
that when they haven't raised the
minimum wage in 10 years and they've cut
back on a whole variety of programs to
working people and poor people so I
think that what has to happen in
communities around this country is
articulate the issues have the guts to
stand up to the people who own your
community will dominate the two major
parties and you'd be surprised with the
results you'll get the other parties do
talk about housing they talk about
health care they talk about those issues
tell me what makes your approach
different well I should point out that
not only have I been elected mayor
Burlington four times I recently ran for
Congress in november and i lost the
election but in doing so we put together
a really very exciting campaign we had
500 volunteers we had 2,300 Vermont is
contributing to the campaign and I lost
the fellow who won Peter Smith got
forty-one percent I got thirty-eight
percent and the Democrat came in third
with eighteen percent and what it showed
it seemed to me is that at least in
Vermont people are prepared to go beyond
the labels of Democrat Republican and
respond to a call for radical change in
this country so what are the issues we
talked about housing for the issue in
terms of housing the issue in terms of
health care are not complicated in terms
of health care the United States of
America today is one of two
industrialized nations in the world that
does not have in one form or another a
national health care system which
guarantees healthcare to all of its
people without out-of-pocket expenses
the other nation that has lacks a
national health care system is South
Africa which tells us that we might want
to think about moving in a different
direction
art and the issue in terms of help get
very important sure I talked about it a
lot over month should the health care
system be run as it presently is
basically the guarantee significant
profits for the drug companies to the
hospitals for the medical equipment
suppliers to the insurance companies or
should we try to provide the best
quality of health care that we can
including a lot of preventive health
care in a non-profit type of way okay we
live in Burlington 50 miles away from
Canada in Canada today you have a
conservative government that has no
desire whatsoever to touch in any way
the national health care system that
they have because they be thrown out of
office if they did that now Canada who
our country can provide health care to
all of its people why can't we do that
in the United States of America and I
think the answer is the night of the
democratic or republican party has the
guts to stand up to the medical
industrial complex which is a very
powerful grouper p our topic tonight is
third party politics and our guest is
Bernard Sanders a veteran mayor from
Burlington Vermont he is a member of the
socialist progressive coalition party
technically progressive coalition
progressive coalition hey you're as you
mentioned earlier you're currently
serving your fourth two-year term and
this will be your last term you're the
only socialist mayor in the united
states prior to the election he was a
historian writer and film producer and
from nineteen seventy six to nineteen
eighty-one he was director of the
American people's Historical Society you
tell us a little about the society what
we did is we produce audio-visual
material on state histories for kids and
we also got around to producing a very
nice television program on the life of
Eugene Debs who you may know was the
founder of the Socialist Party in the
early part of this century and one of
the reasons I went into that area is
that I have a real concern that in terms
of the media we really are through the
mass media in general I want to
congratulate c-span to being an
exception to that rule I think we don't
really get a real glimpse of American
reality on the CBS s and the NBC's and I
think when we talk about why we are
where we are today as a country we have
candidates for the Democratic and
Republican parties never seriously
debating in my view the real issues
facing our country I think the
television and
television industry plays a really
important part in preventing serious
debate about the major issues facing our
country as a candidate for office for
example you know that when you get on
television you have 30 seconds to
articulate your point of view you know
that you're dependent upon 30-second ads
and I think it is absolutely imperative
if we if we talk about bringing back a
sense of democracy to this country where
people don't sit just sit and watch
other people but feel that this is their
country and that they can shape it we've
got to make radical changes in the
television industry and the demand the
man that they deal with the important
issues facing elsif I'd like danda you
have a degree in political science from
the University of Chicago and originally
from brooklyn new york we taking your
calls in just a few moments the numbers
again will be listed throughout the show
at the bottom of the screen again the 30
day policy you've called in within the
last month wait let's give someone else
a chance to get through at the national
level why a third party we've touched on
it a little bit something let's look at
the reality of what's going on right now
we just came through a presidential
election I think it's fair to say even
if people don't hold my own political
perspective that most people want to say
the least disenchanted with the election
you have a situation where half of the
American people didn't bother voting
okay we have in the United States today
the lowest turnout of any industrialized
nation in the entire world by and large
poor people in the United States no
longer vote you and we all sit and say
isn't a terrible in South Africa blacks
can't vote let's face reality than the
United States the vast majority of poor
people don't vote why do half the people
not vote for president and a North
presidential years even fewer people
vote state elections local election very
few people vote and I think the reason
is that people perceive that government
does not represent their interests what
difference does it really make Michael
Dukakis says my campaign is about
confidence not ideology what he's really
saying is folks there's not a whole lot
of difference between the Democrats and
Republicans you have a situation in the
country today where one percent of the
population owns on behalf of the wealth
in this country the richest ten percent
own over eighty-three percent of the
wealth and the last several years
we had a doubling a billionaire's in
this country at the same time as you
have three million people sleeping out
in the street last year the chief
executive officers of the largest
corporations received a forty-eight
percent increase in their take-home pay
the average American worker receives a
three or four percent okay fifteen
percent of our people have no health
insurance who is addressing the issues
that face the vast majority of our
people I think Congress in a sense no
longer represents the ordinary people
and Congress was made up of the
Democrats and Republicans you know
people very often were yelling at the
Republicans and Reagan look at the
horrible priorities he established with
all the terrible things that he did to
the poor people but they forgot that
both houses of the Congress before out
of ravens eight years were controlled by
the Democrats I think you have
bipartisan policy which essentially
favors the rich at the expense of
working people in the poor people I
think we need to go the direction of
Canada which has a third party
Democratic Socialist Party we may not
win right away but our job is to bring
together workers and poor people
minorities environmental groups
environmentalist let's come together
articulate the issues and I think we're
going to make some real progress first
calls from right at home Burlington boy
you're on the air go right ahead Mr
Sanders well I believe that you are
introduced as a socialist I read
somewhere that you did not or you do not
or you never have belonged to the
Socialist Party is that correct that's
true have you ever belonged to the
Communist story oh I haven't thank you
very much I think it's an interesting
question I am a socialist there are in
our country probably a dozen different
socialist parties none of them have
terribly much influence I have not to be
a member of any my goal is to see that
we thought a third party in this country
which represents as I indicated before a
wide spectrum of people but I'm not him
that look like a few years ago there was
a third party formed and mr. Anderson
ran and did okay I guess your comments
well mr. Anderson's third party f it did
not impress me as much as very common is
on the citizens body I think mr.
Anderson's
f it was essentially I mean I give him
credit for going beyond the Democratic
and Republican parties but to my mind it
was a fairly conservative effort I think
Barry commoner people in the citizens
party made a more serious epic about
[ __ ] for working people
environmentalists and really challenged
the system from a class basis and a real
political basis much more profoundly
than did miss Anderson who in fact was a
Republican congressman do you think
Anderson get more publicity though yes
oh yeah how high is that well I think
you're raising a very important question
and that is one of the difficulties that
one has in terms of developing a third
party in this country is dealing with a
media which is increasingly dominated by
large corporations and it is no great
secret that large corporations who own
the newspapers who own the television
stations who own the radio stations are
not terribly anxious to give a good
hearing two viewpoints which challenge
their economic interests and that's
that's really a basic problem that we're
gonna have to deal with I'd like to talk
more about that on your particular
campaign at first let's go out to
seattle washington go right ahead yes
I'm we just didn't talking to a
socialist because it's so hard to find
one anymore and I want to know what you
thought of Reverend Jesse Jackson's
campaign whether you agree with most of
those points that he was making and I
want to give you one little footnote
that the some interest I think my niece
has had uncles on both sides of their
families or mothers and their fathers
named Eugene be as in Victor much in
Burlington we had a real debate about
our attitude toward Jesse Jackson's
campaign I think many of us were
impressed by the physicians the Jackson
was bringing forth we were deeply
impressed by the concept of the rainbow
coalition which i believe is exactly
what has to be done in this country and
we were impressed by Jackson's charisma
and is going into the ghettos and into
the poor areas and speaking for the
family farmers were being thrown off of
their land and that moved us very much
the problem that we had is that of
course Jackson was functioning within
the Democratic Party and we're not
Democrat so we had a
discussion within our own organization
and we ended up saying yeah we're not
Democrats but we think with Jackson was
doing was so important that we are going
to support them and for one night in
Vermont we did go into the Democratic
Party and in fact Jackson ended up
winning the Democratic caucuses so I was
sympathetic to Jackson I agree with the
concept of the rainbow coalition I do
disagree with Jessie in terms of whether
the Democratic Party can be the real
vehicle for social change I believe it
should be a third time how would you
assess the media courage or your
campaign was it fair to you yeah in
Vermont you don't after your mayor for
eight years i think i am not treated
differently than other candidates i'm
not going to tell you that I'm fine
picked on or discriminated against the
problem that I have and I think the same
problem that any any serious candidate
has is you can't deal with complex
issues in the 24 seconds that you get
when somebody sits a microphone in front
of you and gives you only a certain
amount of time that's not just my
problem George Bush's problem it's
anybody's problem and the question we
had I know in my particular campaign
something like 25 debates all around the
state and constantly you were asked to
give your view on how you solve the
budget deficit in one minute well you
know what you can't do it in one minute
I think and this is an important point
that I want to reiterate you are not
going to have serious discussion of the
issues facing this country you're not
going to be able to educate our
population and I have to say that in my
view the American people are
significantly less politically conscious
and understanding of what goes around
them than most of the people around the
world and one of the reasons is the
collapse of the media in terms of
allowing serious people with different
points of view to go forward and debate
the real issues of our time or even to
bring on the television set up for
example we face as all people know an
ecological crisis and I find whether
it's acid rain the destruction of the
ozone layer the greenhouse effect one
would think that the CBS's and the NBC's
of the world will be doing primetime
specials on these programs having
different scientists talking about the
issues involving people and
understanding what's going on in terms
of our planet they don't the function of
television is to make as much money as
possible for the owners of the
television station and for those people
who advertise
30-second ads on television so I would
say that we're not going to bring about
serious political change in this country
until we deal with the media which more
and more is being swallowed up by large
conglomerates very important issue let's
go to Western Massachusetts Amherst your
on air oh yes I like the first thing
she's been for uh let me have the
opportunity to speak and I just like to
let you know that I it's so refreshing
to hear someone speak to reality just
listening to ABC CBS NBC and the rest of
the station you get absolutely nothing
and mr. standards I supports you a
hundred percent on the question that I
wanted to ask you is that there's a old
marketing concept which I think you
might be familiar with it goes something
like this those who are not in control
of the mental means of production are
subject to it and I think you're exactly
right when you you know look at the
corporate interest behind ABC CBS NBC
and a lot of the other's establishment
news organizations and I just wish you
could elaborate a little bit more on
that but I just support you so much and
it's so nice to hear someone speaking to
reality thank you thank you very much
let me touch on the subject because
again it's an issue that I think does
not get the type of discussion certainly
on commercial television needless to say
that a triple what what is television
about an entire network but let's think
about it for a moment I think no one
denies certainly not the networks
themselves that their function is to
make as much money as they can you stop
for a moment and you turn on the
television you're constantly bombarded
with 30-second ads you talk to teachers
and you say what is this due to the
attention span of the kids the kids
watch television 40 50 hours a week what
it means is that kids are losing the
ability to concentrate because they're
constantly being interrupted by moronic
ends and we have talking toilet seats
and porking kittens and so forth and so
on your programs are primarily built
around the ads themselves that built to
end at a certain climatic moment and you
flip into the 32nd of commercial
television some people some people think
the television is a hopeless technology
that it can't be reformed I disagree
with that
I think the television had extraordinary
potential but I think that just as we
are beginning as a nation to stand up to
the polluters who pollute our air and
our water and our earth I think we've
got to stand up and say to the
television networks you are transmitting
your television by a public airwaves and
you have certain responsibilities you
have got to help educate the people
about what's going on you've gotta let
political parties and people discuss
their points of view and you can't just
use those airwaves to make as much money
as possible for yourself that's an issue
that has not been debated anywhere near
as seriously as your truck even with the
public television network for example
just look at the PBS how many
progressive programs are there on the
PBS you have the right wing programs
from national review on you have the
mobil oil programs how many programs
come from a left point of view which
reflect the needs of working people
employed for people virtually not so
even the PBS which is ostensibly the
public station is dominated by corporate
power go to California Monterey you're
on the air hello Mr Sanders right okay
I'm a Vermont reform on resident from
down by Rutland who has moved to
Monterey via Japan I spent the last
three years in Japan and especially at
the time of the election and I was I was
disenchanted it was like one of those
horrible questionnaires where somebody
hands you these multiple choice
questions and you want to rewrite the
questions I am I I'm behind you on a
third a viable third party hello okay
it's the redhead well that that I'm just
I'm voicing my support good thank you
very much a funny thing happened
recently I wrote an op-ed piece which
appeared in The New York Times on
january third 1989 very nice little time
to printed and I was astounded by the
response that this article got basically
had said that the Democrats and
Republicans are not dealing with the
real issues facing working people in
terms of Environmental Protection in
terms of raising the minimum wage in
terms of healthcare housing etc etc and
the letters came in by the dozens and
dozens and
and what that response indicates to me
that there is out there throughout this
country especially among working people
and poor people and then people
concerned about peace and the
environment a tremendous is this
gentleman said disenchantment with
status quo politics and the my hope is
and certainly my hope is that we're
going to go beyond the Democrats and
Republicans let's go back up Burlington
Vermont right ahead uh yes sir am I on
now yes go right ahead you can talk to
you mayor well this is a local issue and
I'm I'm wondering how the mayor can feel
justified with a question that's going
to be on the ballot in March subsidizing
child care now the child care is a very
important issue all over the country but
my question is if he could explain to
the viewers how how he's comfortable
pointing the finger at 49 second-class
license holder in the City of Burlington
you know to subsidize the Burlington
share and in another follow-up thing is
the promotions are downtown Burlington
shop and Burlington and how he can
justify putting on this proposal you
still expect people to shop in the city
of Berlin and the gentleman raises let
me explain a little bit probably the
rest of the nation does not know what's
going to be on the ballot in Burlington
they will soon they will so tonight all
over in Burlington we have as exists
throughout our state and in fact
throughout this nation as you know a
very serious problem regarding child
care while we spend 300 billion dollars
on the military and give tax breaks to
corporations and wealthy people the
federal government has been unable to
provide any kind of substantial sums of
money for child care so you have all
over this country working mothers
families paying a huge percentage of
their income if you're making 300 bucks
a week and you want a kid to go your kid
to go to a decent child kiss has a fine
to 80 and 90 bucks I mean it's really
prohibitive in honesty all honestly the
solution should come from the federal
government they have the capabilities of
raising revenue in a progressive manner
but they choose to give tax breaks to
the rich and spend money on a nuclear
weaponry we've given up on the federal
government they clearly are not going to
do it that's why some of us are not in a
mid with the Democrats and Republican
state government should be doing a lot
more in Vermont throughout the nation
our state government does a little bit
nowhere near but we have a problem so I
think as mayor of our city that we've
got to address that problem so what the
gentleman is talking about is there is a
an issue that's going before the people
of our city which will enable us to
raise a million and a quarter dollars
for a child care Development Fund based
on an expansion of our gross receipts
tax oh yes I mentioned about shopping
well I mean the theory is he raises
another issue okay you see during my
eight years as mayor every time not it
almost everybody we have tried to
develop progressive taxation we're done
what we thought was right for working
people or the elderly people are poor
people basically it comes down to who's
going to pay I do not believe in the
property tax i think the property tax in
vermont throughout this nation is a
regressive and unfair form of Taxation
we have looked for progressive
alternatives every time we do it the
rich people in the business community
says you're going to drive business out
of Burlington you're a terrible mayor
and so forth and so well the reality is
Burlington right now is one of the
lowest unemployment rates in the United
States our problem is not driving
business out our problem is now
controlling development but the answer
is question I think increasingly the
people who have the money the business
community with property values of
soaring soaring while making very good
profits they're going to have to help us
with childcare they're going to have to
help us with housing I'm not going to go
to working people for people and raise
their taxes to pay for these needs let's
go to a Reno Nevada go right ahead the
USSR is an a perfect example of
socialism and it hasn't gotten anywhere
in all these years the communism is dead
I don't understand how you can apply it
to a city the let's say for example the
Speaker of the House the mr. Dowd mr.
Dellums these people are socialists and
they are always just like in Russia and
mr. Gorbachev saying
the people on top always want to have
the best and they take the profits of
the country like the nomenklatura in the
socialist Russia Wow can we say mr.
Wright wants everyone to get fifty
percent more money he is taking the
judges in the city and giving them from
79002 135,000 so he can control the
courts and they'll be no reapportionment
for the Republicans that the same party
will stay in the difference in socialism
to me in the city is like when they took
my land they Ruiz owned it and that way
they could keep it there was no way for
me to utilize my land is that how you
apply it and can you tell me how can you
tell me how can you possibly a run a
country on the basis where the people on
top just call themselves socialists but
they're they're worse than the Capitals
because they don't give you freedom they
take what they want and they make the
judges in the laws the way they want
them right let me just jump in here well
I am not aware that the people who run
this country I haven't been aware lately
the mr. Bush I didn't see the paper
today but I did not know that mr. Bush
announced that he was a socialist or
that many members of the United States
Congress has announced that they were
socialists were the supreme court has
announced that they are social afire I
don't quite understand the thrust of the
country if the woman feels that zoning
the socialistic I disagree with up to
north windham main go right ahead yes
sir on this free patty system I have a
small little statement and then a very
quick question it would appear to me
that it's already here that the people
of the United States of America that
takes the time to write their
congressmen in their Senators to stop
all pay raises and they the
representatives none of them listen then
I would say the three-party system is
already here thank you very much and
I'll be listening for you well I think
with the gentleman you know it's a funny
as soon as that business came out we
spoke out about it in Vermont and a lot
of people you know responded to that all
over this country now people are cannot
believe that a united states congress
which has not raised the minimum wage
in 10 years which has cut programs for
the poor that these people are going on
televisions like gee we just can't make
it with eighty nine thousand five
hundred dollars plus a lot of very nice
benefits we need a fifty percent
increase what that is about is the
arrogance of power and it's related to
the fact that in the last election I
don't know how many people know this
ninety-nine percent of the incumbent
congressman were reelected okay in other
words what you're seeing now in the
United States Congress is a situation
number one we have a lot of very very
wealthy people one-third of the United
States Senate a millionaire's a lot of
the congressman I'm doing at number two
when you're an incumbent congressman you
can pick up a lot of corporate pack
support you have a lot of name
recognition yeah franking privilege is
you're on TV every day basically you're
seeing the creation of a government
which is isolated and unaccountable to
the people and apparently cannot be
recalled by the people there was a
bigger turnover in the Politburo in the
Soviet Union last year then in the
United States Congress now that's a real
problem and the arrogance went that far
is to say to the American people you
average worker who saw a three or four
percent increase in your salary you're
making twenty or thirty thousand bucks
if you're lucky we we only make an
eighty nine thousand we're going to get
a fifty percent decrease in our salaries
now in fact is that gentleman has
indicated maybe the Congress went a
little bit too far this time and thief
is a result of work of people like Ralph
Nader and many others there's been a
real citizens uprising against back and
if that helps lead to a third party
demonstrating the arrogance of Congress
certainly i'll be very happy about that
let's go to san francisco for our next
call hi how are you okay i just like to
say go for it miss defenders were people
you have no idea how many people are
with you on this one i would just like
to say well i would like to ask you um
is there somewhere you can enunciate a
plan of action for people to go after
this i mean there is a strong need there
is a strong desire as American body
politic for a third party what is it
that we can do what can I do you like it
well here's the point first of all I
don't think that there any magical
solution we all understand that it's a
lot more difficult to actually bring
about a strong third party than it is to
some
talk about it but one of the things that
we can do there are couple of things
that we can do there is a group in New
York City that I'm affiliated with
called the National Committee for
independent political action and sipping
really very fine people who are already
beginning that process of developing
independent political action that's
number one number two probably more
importantly I think it is idealistic and
mythical to believe that you're going to
bring people together and start a
national third party like that you know
snap your fingers I think that what it's
got to happen is in community after
community all over this country in san
francisco in los angeles in vermont
start standing up bringing people
together don't keep voting for the
lesser of two evils articulate what the
real issues are and the issues are very
clear we're building expensive housing
but no housing for middle-income people
are poor people the rich get richer the
poor get poorer the priorities of the
national government are totally absurd
more and more money for military
spending less for human needs we're
becoming less and less of a democratic
nation let's deal with corporate control
of the media the issues are really there
what we need is the guts to stand up to
the ruling class and the big money
interest who dominate the cities and the
towns and the states of her life of the
nation in Vermont and I think what has
to happen is a party develops in San
Francisco party develops in LA a party
develops in Boston let's move and when
we get the grassroots moving then we
come together I think we do it from down
and then go to the top rather than the
other way go down to Panama City Florida
go right ahead yes I just like to
address of generally everything he said
frankly he's like you know that America
is in bad shape right now we have people
sleeping on the sea we have a lot of
things that are just not very deaf but
we can't handle that and the framework
that we have now it's good that we have
choices and we can have him on the air
and anybody else on the air but I think
our biggest problem right now is not who
we elect but who we respect and the
problem in America
is that we have lost respect for the
true history of America and where we
really came from and why we were really
for see this country was formed on
freedom to worship God and we've lost
that so and we have a loss that we've
given it up but right now we still have
choices are we on the first of losing
them because God tells me that everyday
we sit series the fact that we have
choices all right thank you very much
Panama City Electric is jumping okay
let's go out to 10 more Washington
you're on ear thank you very much she's
been congratulations having this
gentleman on the week exposing but the
things it there what the people have to
realize it that we can be fooled you
know we've been fooled many more many
times by me well even Castro said he was
not a communist but we found out later
was ever different but the thing is for
socialism was it's not decent socialism
a communist socialism for that to exist
The Bella write the Constitution of the
United States had to be done away with
and we know what socialism is it grew by
the few chosen few in the government
forevermore we found that out we know
what that is so I can't see why next
earth why we should not have a some of
the Nazi a socialist up here now that we
have a communist socialist quick well I
mean I'm glad that he raises the
question and this has to do with an
extraordinary ignorance in this country
in terms of the difference between
communism and socialism socialism is not
communist soviet union has been for many
many years to decades in authoritarian
society many of us are hopeful that at
the present moment some of those who are
territorial structures are being broken
down and we hope that that continues we
hope the democracy comes to the Soviet
en it is not a democratic society but
when people like this gentleman do not
know is for example that in Scandinavia
in Sweden you have had socialist
governments for decades that in fact
that country is probably in most
respects more democratic than the United
States they have eighty or ninety
percent of the people voting they have
strong labor unions they have a more
open media they have a healthcare system
guaranteeing health care all
the people not to say that that's utopia
but to say in Canada north of us you
have two provinces which have been
governed by a socialist hyper government
so equate socialism with communism is
simply ignorance but i'm afraid that too
much of that ignorance exists in our own
country at various times the governments
of nicaragua and previous the previous
government of grenada have said that
they were not communists were socialists
Marxists dude yeah how do you relate lat
I agree with that you know what they
said but the government of Grenada said
under Maurice Bishop is that they wanted
to forge their own way and they were
overthrown by the United States
government in Nicaragua you have a
government which has came to power and I
believe has tried to do the right things
for his people in terms of health care
land reform education if you trace the
history of the United States visa the
Latin America and Central America there
has never been a time when a country
made a revolution for the poor people
where it was not overthrown by the CIA
or the United States government or the
Marines Salvador Allende was
democratically elected by the people of
chile he made the mistake of believing
that his job as president of that
country was to represent the people of
chili and he did his best and he was
overthrown by the CIA so the interesting
question is why does the United States
government think whether it's nicaragua
or any other country in Latin of Central
America then it has the right to
overthrow those governments let's go
down to Chapel Hill North Carolina go
right ahead you're on the air mayor
Sanders hello we agree with you about
what you're saying about corporate
control of the media that's obviously a
serious problem because we're not
educating the people to the problems but
one of the bigger problems that we see
is it doesn't seem to be in the economic
world a level playing field we have
practices like retained earnings by
corporations but we've completely done
away with any semblance of that in the
private and individual sector for
example IRAs and things of that nature
individual pages taxes up front before
he gets his paycheck
the corporation does not pay its taxes
if it puts it in a retained earnings
account ever that's not double taxation
what would you say about changing that
provision and a few similar provisions
in the IRS to level the economic playing
field maybe that's the problem not a
class struggle well I would say that
that problem is a reflection of the
class struggle because it is not an
accident that those types of breaks are
given the large and powerful corporation
it's not an accident that during the
last eight years we have given hundreds
of billions of dollars in tax breaks a
huge corporation at the same time that
poor people through sales taxes and
property taxes have had to pay more it
is not an accident that you have
companies like Philip Morris that are
able to buy out craft for 12 billion
dollars I think it's a mistake to
separate economics from politics in my
view the Congress is very heavily
dominated by corporate power in the
corporate tax and biologic Oh operation
for example I mean I think most people
know Ronald Reagan was an actor in
California and this is no great secret
nothing that I discovered and some
millionaires in California said Ron we
want you to work for us we want you to
become governor and they SAT around the
table move thousand millionaires they
made him governor and then they made him
president and he did his job effectively
for those corporations general electric
for whom he worked for a number of years
before he became a governor and
president over a period of years during
his presidency pay nothing in federal
taxes I think the federal tax situation
needs a radical revision so in moving
toward a progressive tax system will you
ask those individuals and institutions
to start paying their fair share so you
don't squeeze the middle income people
are working people let's go to Portland
Oregon you're on c-span yes hello i want
to say first of all seat Bend are very
pleased I am to hear this gentleman I
listen to a lot of public affairs
programs capital gang crossfire Evans
Novak hours to the extreme capitals
right there absolutely sickening and we
need to get more informed Americans by
programs such as this now I know that
you stay a long ways away from me you
shy away from anyone suggesting
communism and a lot of people think
socialism is very much the same but
they're only saying that communism and
they mean so show us very much doesn't
work anywhere but I say that our country
is not working very well here in
Portland Oregon we have to forego many
things that would make our city more
beautiful more livable and would create
better living conditions because the
crime and violence it seems to me that
if America can't handle the problems of
crime drugs and violence something is
wrong and that socialist countries do
not have the problem even in Soviet
Russia they do not have it all right
thank you very much Portland but let me
let me touch on that I don't think
there's a magic answer to the client
problem which is a serious problem not
only in Portland but all over the
country but clearly what we do on this
man is there is a growing underclass in
the United States of America people who
don't feel part of society don't respect
society they are down below they have no
place to go to those kids doing drug
deals and making a quick buck is a good
thing those kids are not going to
graduate high school you have areas in
America with seventy-five percent of the
kids don't graduate high school I think
we can argue about what socialism means
and let me tell you to be very frank I
don't have a blueprint in my pocket I
don't think there is much all that I
think we have got to begin to say is it
doesn't make sense when this woman
talked about crime and crime is very
often related to drugs and drugs is
related to hopelessness no sane person
destroys their body if they believe that
they have a future in their lives and
what the drug problem means to me is
that you've got millions of people
primarily young people who believe they
ain't going no place and they may as
well shoot up right now and they're
dying they're committing crimes they get
the money to deal with those drugs and
what we as a nation I've got to do is
say is it acceptable that you have a
society which has people with billions
and billions of dollars in wealth
corporations making huge profits not
paying a nickel in taxes and yet you
have educational systems throughout this
country
falling apart and not providing what
these kids need housing needs that are
grossly unmet is the priority system in
this country a rational one and I think
the answer is no and we can argue what
socialism means that we're blue in the
face but I think for a spot what I
believe is that this country has the
wealth to guarantee a decent education
to every child in this country free
education through college if that child
has the ability we have the capabilities
of providing a national health care
system which guarantee you all of the
health care that you need without
out-of-pocket expenses and we have the
capability of providing every American
with decent affordable housing ok I
don't believe that every American has
got to make 20 8422 dollars and where
the same suits you know and March in the
same way that's that's ridiculous but I
do think that we can do it and this
woman raises the crime problem if you
give people hope if you address housing
problem economic problems educational
problem you're going to go a long way to
cutting the drug problem and you're
going to make this a far more civilized
society Bernard Sanders are Burlington
Vermont socialist man thanks very much
for being with us my pleasure and thank
you for your calls and have a good
weekend good night